j'imagine que vous allez tous aller
voter ce dimanche est-ce que sylvie
Goulard vous serez près de vous à mettre
un bulletin les républicains dans Lyon
si nécessaire moi je salue le courage
des socialistes qui se sont retirés je
pense que pour l'image internationale de
la France est un geste majeur je pense
qu'il y a une différence fondamentale
entre des gens dont je ne partage pas
toutes les idées mais que je respecte
avec qui je peux travailler et des
individus qui donnent de la France
l'image de haine et de violence que
Madame Le Pen a donné face à Madame
Merkel au Parlement européen c'est à
dire un flot d'insultes et de xénophobie
et de haine en plus c'est un clan
familial qui est en train de mettre la
France sous coupe réglée dont je n'ai
pas d'état d'âme je voterai pour tous
les modérée qui pourront lui faire
barrage et vous Eduard Martin vous allez
soutenir
effectivement j'aurais aimé que sylvie
Goulard qui salue ceux qui se sont
désistés pour son parti enfin en tout
cas sans l'alliance condamne de la même
manière régner qui lui se maintient et
qui condamne peut-être les propos à ce
point hier soir ou Monsieur Nicolas
Sarkozy vous voyez trouve alors il nous
explique y compris les républicains et
ses alliés que le Front National est à
parti dangereux qui va mettre le pays
chaos et je partage assez et en même
temps leur représentant hier soir
annonce que il n'est pas immoral de
voter franc national donc chercher
l'erreur